hey Collider fans
it's your resident Transformers fan John
Roca here breaking down why bumblebee is
the most authentic Transformers movie
yet I'm assuming if you've clicked on
this that you've seen this latest
installment from Travis Knight and
starring Hailee Steinfeld but if you
haven't then hit pause on this video
right now go to your local movie theater
watch the movie come back and hit play
still watching
ok let's roll out the Transformers came
into prominence in the 1980s with a
beloved TV series generation 1 or g1
toys and figures and a legendary
animated feature film that introduced
some of us to the concept that heroes
die for the first time a whole
generation of fans grew up watching the
animated series over their breakfast
cereals during that time so Travis
Knight smartly sets the film in 1989 and
takes viewers back to the decade that
was the heyday of this franchise he
feels it with 80s references like a
Walkman the TV show Alf mopeds the John
Hughes classic The Breakfast Club the
80s songs from the Smiths and Tears for
Fears
and to bring it full circle we even get
a character eating mr. T's breakfast
cereal in the movie by going back in
time night lays a foundation of
authenticity for the Transformers fans
who did not like Bay's version of the
Transformers movies or felt that didn't
land with them now let's look at that
incredible battle scene on Cybertron
that opens bumblebee next we rarely get
to see the legendary battle between the
Autobots and Decepticons on their home
planet but the movie wastes no time
bringing it to you the planet looks
incredible and feels real instead of
piecemeal like we've seen it before the
Bay movies Knight also smartly includes
a good amount of Transformers in their
original g1 designs along with the
classic red blue and white tractor
trailer look of Optimus Prime you have
the yellow g1 design of bumblebee along
with Soundwave shockwave ravage
Wheeljack and Cliffjumper it's this
old-school look that fans have been
clamoring for to see since the first
live-action Transformers movie was
announced night bringing them to life
like this in an environment like this
also checks the authenticity box for the
film but the biggest reason that this is
the most authentic Transformers movie is
the relationship between Hayley
Stanfield's Charlie Watson and bumblebee
Charlie has lost her father in the film
and it's a bit of drift just like bummed
we is when she stumbles upon him bumble
has lost his voice
and his memory thanks to an earlier
altercation with a Decepticon this ups
the film to focus on the relationship
between the two as they become friends
and end up saving each other in more
ways than one
we get the old-school look of bumblebee
as a yellow VW bug and a teenager having
to keep him a secret from other humans
just like the young teenagers did in the
animated series the fact that bumblebee
has lost his memory also keeps the film
from getting too bogged down in the epic
war and soldiers aspect that was the
hallmark of the previous 5 Michael Bay
Transformers movies we can watch our Li
connect with a transformer just like a
lot of us did when we first discovered
them all of these decisions by night
make the film feel like a live-action
extended episode of the old-school
animated series and what could make a
Transformers movie feel more authentic
than that and just in case you're like I
don't know Roca you like those Bay
former's movies
I hear you Collider fans so don't take
only my word for it it was recently
certified fresh' by Rotten Tomatoes
comments from critics and fans range
from Peter debruge at variety describing
bumble bee as basically the movie that
fans of the 1980s animated series wanted
all along
followed by Justin Lowe at The Hollywood
Reporter calling the film an affective
reimagining that also bears annoing
resemblance to classic youth oriented
films from bumble bee executive producer
Steven Spielberg my fellow Transformers
fans Kristian harloff and Dennis Zeng
commented the Travis Knights saved
transformers and that old-school g1 fans
will be pleased and there's potential
for even better things to come and even
our very own Perry Nemerov who has been
my nemesis in our transformers versus
Power Rangers eternal war tweeted I
cannot believe I like the Transformers
movie even more than roca so look it
even Perry who's a notorious stickler
for details is back in the transformers
camp then you know bumblebee is the best
Transformers movie yet well there are
the reasons why bumblebee is the most
authentic Transformers movie thank you
for letting this Transformers fan and g1
fan break this one down for you let us
know what you thought of these reasons
in the comments section below
remember to like and share this video on
your social media and subscribe to the
collider quick channel for more fun
videos just like this one now if you'll
excuse me I'm gonna go pull out my g1
toys and stage my own battle on
Cybertron
[Music]
you